altimeter data confirmed
the excitement from these nasa
scientists and engineers was clear
as they made space flight history
these still images from mars show
ingenuity
the first helicopter ever to fly on
another planet
and then came the video it's grounded at
first and then
shows us hovering our three meters above
the martian surface and then touching
back down it's amazing
brilliant we know that our time to make
a difference
at jezreel crater mars is not yet over
this is just a first great flight
congratulations
take that moment and then after that
let's get back to work and more flights
congratulations
ingenuity took off from the dusty red
surface
of mars jazeera crater early on monday
but the data took several hours to reach
earth
a milestone for space flight that nasa
scientists compared to the first flight
on earth
by the wright brothers in 1903
technology demonstrations are really
important for all of us you know it's
really
taking a tool that we haven't been able
to use and put it in the box of tools
that is available for all of our
missions going forward at mars
if we really want to explore the red
planet explore possibility of past life
present
microbes and things like that under
different
conditions on the martian surface we're
going to need to be able to travel
greater distances
which a helicopter like this would
absolutely allow in the future
[Music]
flying a helicopter or drone is a
seemingly simple task on earth
but engineers aren't used to flying them
on mars
the flight can be affected by many
things the martian atmosphere is very
thin
and so it's more difficult for the
helicopter's 1.2 meter rotary blades
to lift itself up
[Music]
in its test flight on earth scientists
had to create conditions similar to mars
the ingenuity weighs 1.8 kilograms on
earth
but only 0.68 kilograms on mars
its batteries can also be affected by
temperature
on mars that's an average of minus 53
degrees celsius
ingenuity isn't alone it hitched a ride
to the red planet
on nasa's perseverance rover which
touched down in february
and will soon begin to explore the mars
surface
ingenuity is expected to conduct more
flight tests
with the hope that one day it can travel
further
as part of nasa's quest to find any
signs of life
on mars laura burden manly al jazeera
for more on this we can bring in lua el
basuni he's a power electronics lead
engineer who worked on the ingenuity
mars helicopter team with nasa
jpl and he joins us via skype from los
angeles great to have you with us and
congratulations
on a successful flight i could see your
huge smile as you were watching the
celebrations there in laura's report
yes i mean thank you thank you i mean
it's really exciting time i mean i
cannot
express my feelings i mean since early i
mean been up really early in the morning
watching the feed
life for mars and it's just been really
you know
i mean the happiest day in my life it's
um to be part of such a great team and
to achieve such a great achievement oh
well we're very happy to be able to
speak to you about it now i mean the
conditions on mars
they make it very difficult don't they
to get such
um an apparatus airborne how did you
overcome these difficulties
samuel i mean this is that we had to
like you know be part of the big team
like you know to decide on
on a lot of the study how you know that
can we fly on another planet
i mean especially mars and we studied
like the atmosphere and
a lot of this translated down into like
the size of the
propeller and you know and then the the
speed that this propeller is turning and
how light the entire aircraft i mean one
of the biggest challenges we had that
we had to actually achieve the weight so
this is like when i first like joined in
the pro in the project i mean i get
tasked with like this very small weight
like
a few few grams to design a motor
inverter
to control the motor and then like we
had to design a very light motor to be
part of the rotor system
i mean that's part of the team i worked
on and so i mean that a lot
of that and this is only like from the
weight and the visibility of
flight and then the other thing come in
the environmental aspect
like you know the temperature we had to
really design things to work for
negative 100 degrees c i mean the motor
inverter itself would actually live in
the mars atmosphere unlike a lot of the
other electronics live in the warm box
box you see in the bottom so actually
that live in the top order so i mean i
had to
this is part of the design design so we
had to do a lot of like
designing for like negative 100 degrees
c which is very uncommon using
electronics we use on earth
i mean we most electronic goes negative
four ac
and the same time we have to consider a
lot of the space radiation the the
vibration from the trip
you know a lot of other things we had to
consider
and and the flight itself it had to be
automated didn't it because it's just
the distance between earth and mars is
300 million kilometers and you're not
you can't use a joystick
uh to do that and you you didn't find
out about
the success of it until is it three
hours later
yes i mean so i mean there the
communication take up
roughly about 39 minutes for the
transmission
the helicopter communicate to a base
station on the rover and they're over
talked to
you know through the dsn system that
actually communicate through
two satellites around mars through like
few satellites on earth so
and then by the time you get all the
data especially when you have a lot of
data you have to process that thing a
little bit longer longer time
and you have to like decode it so that's
what party added to the time
that took until like we got all the
informations
that's absolutely extraordinary feat and
it's fantastic to be able to speak to
you a little bit about it
congratulations again
louie albas uni thank you